[موسيقى]
هنا اول موقع سعودي صنف على لائحه يونسكو
للتراث العالمي عام 2008 الحجر يحمل بصمات
حضاره ومملكه الانباط التي نشات في
المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه لشبه الجزيره
العربيه نشاهد معكم مقابر اثريه منحوته
يدويا تحمل بصمات حضاره الانباط على مر
التاريخ
[موسيقى]
قصر الفريد الذي يعد معلما سياحيا هاما من
اشهر مقابر الحجر واكبرها والصور السياحيه
المرتبطه بها ويتميز بواجه ضخمه يلاحظ
فيها دقه وجماليه النحت هنا
[موسيقى]
كثرت الروايات والحكايات التي تحوم حول
قصر البنات هذه المقبره التي نشاهدها الان
يقال بان فتاه جمعتها علاقه حب مع احد
نحاتي مملكه الانباط فقتلها والدها هذا هو
قصر الملك
[موسيقى]
هنا ديوان موجود في اعلى نقطه هنا في
الحجر كبار الشخصيات والقاده في مملكه
الانباط كانوا يلتقون هنا في هذه المنطقه
الدينيه التي تحولت بعد الاسلام الى ممر
لقوافل الحجاج والتجاره
[موسيقى]
التي تعد اخر مركز لمخطط رحله عبر الزمن
المخطط الذي اطلقه ولي العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان لتفعيل المواقع
التراثيه بقطار سياحي بطول 46 كيلومترا
يمر بالبلده القديمه ثم
الواحه النبطيه وصولا الى هنا الى الحجر
[موسيقى]